his language is violent because
he might think oh yeah i'm going to call
it the chinese virus or the china virus
when you choose to use language that
actually
is violent to real human beings that is
really scary
very exciting news because you're the
new face of neutrogena
what does it mean to you it means
everything to me i think that just
also being an asian-american woman when
i was growing up i didn't often see
if ever a face that looked like me in
like
mainstream household name brands
now the fact that neutrogena had wanted
to work with me
for a asian american face to be a part
of their brand that is just so iconic
and a staple in so many people's homes
like that meant the world to me because
i felt like
man i think we can really do something
skin care and beauty is fantastic but
something even more
than that which is just representation
and
giving hope to younger girls and guys
and
and everyone in general not to be
dramatic but i do feel like i was kind
of put on
this earth to make people feel
seen and loved and wanted like all the
time
young girls will come up to me and tell
me like how they feel represented and
how they you know in high school for
them
they feel similar to like past
characters that i played and whatnot so
i just it's like ultimate honor and i
feel really grateful and
fortunate that i'm even in this position
in the first place to even have this
the smallest amount of influence so i
think that honestly i'm just really
grateful
um and i'm hopeful for the future what
do you hope that your
your young fans both female male
everyone can learn from you about beauty
ideals and beauty standards
i want them to learn that anything is
possible if you work
really really hard and you stick to your
guns
and you focus in and believe anything is
possible before i let you go i do want
to talk
just get a little political with you
talk about the upcoming election
you thankfully have been so vocal
about president trump's chosen name for
coven 19
yeah called it the chinese virus yes to
do so
um why did you feel so compelled to to
speak up the way that you did
on on social media about that
he uses very
hateful language on purpose his language
is violent
because he might think oh yeah i'm going
to call it the chinese virus or the
china virus
but what he's really doing is because
he's like oh well it came from china
be that as it may when you choose to use
language that actually is violent to
real human beings that is really scary
i remember when he first started using
the chinese virus
there was an uptick in violence against
asian americans
and discrimination against asian
americans and i've i felt that
just walking outside i didn't even want
to go like to the grocery store
because i felt like there was this new
kind of
stigma that was so it's just his work
his language has
really really it's really impactful and
it makes
it's really scary like oh my god what
are
the president of the united states
should not be so bl like
casually stoking the flames of violence
in his language and in his actions that
just doesn't feel right to me
and i just felt like i needed to say
something
i needed to say something for myself
but greater than that for the community
because i have
other i have other asian american
friends who said the same thing they're
like now i'm kind of i'm scared to go
out
because someone's going to scream at me
or someone's going to harass me or
someone's going to throw something at me
or kick me in the face
and i'm like we should not be living in
fear no one should live in fear and he's
doing this
so i felt the need to speak out on it
because it directly
impacts my life and it directly impacts
my friend's life and and the community
around me
so that is why i spoke out about it and
i will continue to do so and i think
we've got to vote we've got to educate
ourselves
we got to realize that our voice does
matter and it does make a change because
i've seen great change
in the past couple of months but we just
we have
there has to be a change in our
government it's so
scary and i don't even want to think
about what would happen if it didn't go
the way that i
i hope but yeah
[Music]